روسيا ربما قرر بايدن الرحيل لياخذ نصف
البشريه معه وتركيا تتخذ خطوه جريئه في
اوكرانيا وبوتين يفقد اعصابه متواعدا
بالرد وفضيحه امريكيه في الذخائر
العنقوديه والاوكران هم الضحيه ومعاركوا
عنيفه تشهدها الاراضي الاوكرانيه وبولندا
تحشد مقاتلها على الحدود البيلاروسيه فهل
ستندلع حرب جديده معلنه عن الجزء الثاني
من مسلسل الحرب الاوكرانيه والولايات
المتحده تحدد اهدافا جديده بعد 500 يوم من
حرب بوتين على اوكرانيا وكمان جوي روسي
يتسبب بكارثه في اوكرانيا واعداد القتلى
بالمئات والكريم لابن يدرس ضرب المحطات
النوويه لاوروبا فما هو سبب وبيض يدخل خط
الازمه الفلسطينيه ويغيظ تل ابيب
طعنه تركيه في الاجساد الروسيه خطوه
للامام واخرى للوراء اردوغان يتقدم بغرابه
ويدق مسنارا في نعش الصداقه مع بوتين وبعد
يوم من اثاره انقره غضب موسكو عقب قرارها
اعاده خمسه قاده عسكريين اوكرانيين من
كتيبه ازوف الى بلادهم بصحبه الرئيس
الاوكراني
في خطوه وصفتها
اتفاقا لتبادل الاسرى ليلتقط وزير خارجيه
موسكو سيرجيلا
التركي
[موسيقى]
لم يتقبل استقبال تركيا لزلنسكي فما بالنا
بارسال كبار القاده الذين اسرتهم روسيا
ووضعتهم في تركيا كونها وسيطا فتخل
بالاتفاق وترسله مع اوكرانيا وكما يقولها
المثل المصري احفظ اللي باعك واعرف عمل لك
ايه بكره الايام تذله وتعم المزاد عليه خش
عليه بالمصدر يا ابني وكان الرئيس
الاوكراني فولودي قد اعلن عن عوده لبلاده
قادما من تركيا برفقه عدد من قاده مقاتلي
كتيبه ازوف الذين كان قد تم اطلاقه سراحهم
من الاسر لدى القوات الروسيه ونقلهم الى
تركيا وفي اول رد فعل قال الكريم انه لم
يخطر احد روسيا بنقل قاده كتيبه ازوف من
تركيا الى اوكرانيا
اذا فكيف ستنتهي هذه الخطوه التركيه وكيف
سيرد بوتين على صديقه اردوغان ليجيبنا هنا
المتحدث باسم
[موسيقى]
اتفاقات من خلال سماحها بالافراج عن
القاده مضيفا لم تخطر روسيا مسبقا بهذا
القرار مهلا مهلا فهنا تدق انقره اخر في
نعش الصداقه ايضا الاتراك الذين لم يمدوك
بالاسلحه ها هم يبنون مصنعا للطائرات
المسيره واين فيه اوكرانيا شكلها هتولى
حيث اعلن وزير الصناعات الاستراتيجيه
الاوكرانيه
في اوكرانيا بحسب موقع روسيا اليوم
خطوات اردوغان الجريئه ومنخفض ارطغرل الى
حفيد جورج واشنطن وبعد ان قرر بايدن
امدادكي بالذخائر العنقوديه
[موسيقى]
ظهر في اخر مقابله وعليه علامه على وجهه
اشبه بالخدوش ليصرح البيت الابيض لاحقا
انه لا يستطيع النوم الا وهو يرتدي قناع
الاكسجين وان تلك العلامات هي اثر قناع
الاكسجين لنكمل حديثنا فيما اكدت نائبه
مجلس النواب الامريكي
عنقوديه سينتهي بشكل سيء بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده لانه تصعيد للحرب حسب قولها ليعود
يدعو للنظر في ضرب المحطات النوويه
الاوكرانيه والمنشات النوويه في اوروبا
الشرقيه في حال تاكدت معلومات عن توجيه
ضربه باسلحه لمحطه اسمولينز النوويه في
روسيا موسكو لم تعد تمزح بعد اليوم يا
ساده وكما اخبرتكم سابقا شكلات وهنا نعود
باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه لنصوب بوصلتنا
على المعارك الدائره هناك حيث اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه القضاء على اكثر من 60 مئه
جندي وتدمير مستودعات للاسلحه الغربيه
مهلا فلن تمر كل تلك الارقام دون مصادر
ونحن لا نتصفح المصدر امامكم من الموقع
الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه وايضا نشرت
الوزاره الروسيه فيديو لتدمير قافله
دبابات ومدرعات غربيه وسوفيتيه اوكرانيه
خلال هجوم قوتك يييف المضاد الذي روجت له
اوكرانيا والنيتو في المقابل كشف قائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيه ان قوات بلاده
تحرز تقدما بالقرب من مدينه بخمه الشرقيه
البلاد مضيفا ان الجيش الاوكراني يحاصر
حاليا القوات الروسيه في بعض المناطق من
جهه اخرى قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
الولايات المتحده ما زالت ملتزمه بمساعده
اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن نفسها بعد مرور 500
يوم على بدء الغزو الروسي مضيفا ان
الحكومه الروسيه تظل العقابه الوحيده امام
تحقيق سلام عادل ودائم في اوكرانيا حسب
تعبيره وهنا ننتظر الرد الروسي ام ان
الصمت هو اقوى سلاح في وجه الحمقاء كما
تقول موسكو لكن وعلى عكس التيار الغربي
تسبح المانيا حيث نقلت ذيل تيليجراف عن
مصدر في النيتو ان المانيا ستدعو الى
تاجيل انضمام اوكرانيا في قمه بسبب مخاوف
من ان تؤدي العضويه الفوريه الى حرب مع
روسيا وهنا داعم اخر يواصل اعتلاء قائمه
الداعمين حيث ذكرت صحيفه بولس جورنال ان
بولندا زودت كييف مؤخرا باثنتي عشره
مروحيه هجوميه
[موسيقى]
هل ستستعدون مقابل دعمكم جزءا من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه كما يقول التقارير ام ستقبلون
بالمال فقط بولندا لا تعطي شيئا بدون
مقابل رايكم ما هو المقابل فلندا توسع
نظرها قليلا لترمق بلا روسيا هذه المره
وهنا حشد بولندي على حدود بيلاروسيا حيث
قال وزير الدفاع البولندي ماريوس
مع وحده عتاد الى حدودها الشرقيه وسط تزيد
القلق من ان يؤدي وجود مقاتلي مجموعه
الى زياده التوتر على حدودها واضاف وزير
الدفاع البولندي ان هذا يدل على استعداد
بلاده للرد على محاولات زعزعه الاستقرار
بالقرب من حدودها
الاحداث والتطورات
تحلق المستمر لطائرات الجيش السوداني حول
مدن العاصمه الثلاثه تصدت لها قوات الدعم
السريع بالمضادات الارضيه بينما دارت
معارك بين الجيش والدعم السريع بمنطقه
الكلاكله الجنوبيه
اطلاق نار متقطع جنوبي ام درمان وغربي
الخرطوم جدد الرئيس الامريكي في تصريح
صحفي دعمه حل الدولتين باعتباره المسار
الصحيح للمضي قدما في الصراع بين اسرائيل
والفلسطينيين وفي سياق متصل انتقد بعض
اعضاء حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو بسبب موقف من
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]